well there's another one going off here
watch out this was the climax of the
violence on stanway road it had been
building for hours this is the story of
how a road Collision became a run
Ely is about five miles west of Cardiff
City Center this is the earliest footage
we have filmed on Frank Road and now
part of the investigation
5 59 in the evening an electric bike and
a police van apparently following behind
the stretch of road is eight and a half
meters long based on the time taken for
both vehicles to cross the Sky News data
and forensics team calculates their
traveling at around 28 miles an hour
with the van 15 meters behind the bike
officers are called to the scene of the
crash on Snowden Road shortly afterwards
at 603 pm
there are two bodies which we've blurred
to the right of the bus police said the
collision had already occurred when
officers arrived and the no vehicles
were involved but remember the bus it
will help us understand the location
later
a 20 past eight South Wales police
Cardiff tweet to tell people to avoid
coming to the area
police assembled near the intersection
of Snowden road and stanway road to form
a divide between the instant and people
Gathering further down
this is the scene of the accident the
same bus is here down from there on
stanway road more than a hundred people
gather and start throwing projectiles
night falls and the crowd grows more
violent around 10 to 10 they start a
fire it's put out but it's not long
before another is set during the live
stream residents can be heard blaming
police for the death of the two
teenagers in the most heated moments the
crowd attacks police with fireworks in
turn they charge
yeah
the action shifts to high Mead Road
nearby but in the early hours the crowd
disperses the cars still burning Tom
Cheshire Sky News